[Musique - ambiance "mystère"]
Salut. Il y a quelque temps,
à la fin de l'un de mes spectacles,
c'était à Valence,
quelqu'un a laissé une boîte
pour moi.
Cette boîte, apparemment,
avait une histoire
puisqu'elle était accompagnée
d'une lettre, un peu lourde,
avec quelque chose à l'intérieur,
et, euh... je suppose :
des instructions.
Je ne sais qu'une chose,
c'est qu'il a fallu 127h pour créer cette boîte,
et je vais essayer de résoudre l'énigme
avec vous, en face de vous.
[Musique du générique]
Il y a une sorte de tige en bois...
avec les chiffres d'un dé,
de ce côté là
et le un...
Et le 1 qui est au bout, du coup.
On a tous repéré qu'il y avait π
juste ici.
Et quand je mets mon doigt,
je vois qu'il y a comme un ressort,
que je peux l'enfoncer,
mais là je suis au maximum.
Je suis dégoûté, il y a des travaux
en ce moment, mais vraiment !
J'ai l'impression qu'ils sont
en train de percer chez moi, quoi.
Veuillez nous excuser pour
la gêne occasionnée.
De ce côté là : une roue.
Ça, ça tourne.
Ça tourne un peu dans le vide,
mais ça tourne.
Là c'est pareil, on sent
qu'il y a une résistance.
Je découvre donc ce qu'il
y a dedans.
Alors dedans, il y a :
un parchemin.
Quand le temps fut venu,
ils partirent pour les 4 coins de la Terre.
Lorsqu'ils découvrirent le premier Monde,
ils revinrent sur leurs pas compter
le nombre de grains de sable
que le sablier avait laissé filer.
Ils surent, ainsi, combien de temps
ils leur fraudaient pour faire le tour du monde.
C'est à l'heure précise,
à 45238 secondes près,
qu'ils revinrent chez eux.
J'espère que Xavier ne m'a pas
trop surestimé, hein...
Tous trois étaient très heureux de leur voyage
et l'aîné très fier de son calcul.
Toutefois, le plus jeune fît remarquer
que si l'on pouvait voir
le bec du Phoenix à Pâques,
les compteurs seraient remis à zéro.
Avec un petit bout déchiré ici.
La Terre, pour moi, c'est l'objet.
C'est le coffre.
Lorsqu'ils découvrirent le 1er Monde,
ils revinrent sur leurs pas compter le nombre
de grains de sable que le sablier avait laissé filer...
Donc peut-être faire tourner
la boîte en entier,
et la refaire tourner après
en entier dans l'autre sens.
45238 secondes...
Ça fait 753 minutes...
soit 12 heures...
Parce que je me dis que s'il y a
autant de secondes, c'est qu'il faut réduire
pour trouver un truc...
Bon, on trouve ça :
12,56 euh... virgule 6 11 11 11
Alors 12,56, ça, par contre,
ça me parle !
Ça me parle.
Parce que c'est 2 fois Tau.
Et si vous avez regardé la vidéo
que j'avais faite le jour du π-day,
c'est à dire le 14 mars,
j'avais parlé de Tau.
Tau, c'est 6,28.
Et 6,28 fois 2, ça fait 12,56.
Mais comme Tau c'est 2 fois π,
ça veut dire que ce serait 4 fois π.
Et là, ça commence à me parler
parce que π
on l'a ici
Oooohh !
[Rire de surprise]
Alors... Je ne sais pas trop
ce que j'ai fait, là...
Mais j'ai entendu comme une bille
à l'intérieur.
Et donc...
J'ai commencé à tourner,
Je suis revenu en arrière
comme dans l'histoire il y avait marqué :
euh...
Lorsqu'ils découvrirent le premier
Monde, ils revinrent sur leurs pas.
Donc je suis revenu
Et après, j'ai juste fait un tour
entier en fait.
En me disant que ça symbolise
peut-être un tour du Monde complètement.
Alors, je ne sais pas si c'est ça
ou si j'ai pété quelque chose, mais
à la fin, il y a ça qui est sorti.
Complètement.
Et par contre, si je l'enfonce et que je
le tourne, je vois qu'il y a quelque chose, là,
qui se passe, juste au dessus.
Il y a deux espèces de languettes
qui se lèvent comme ça...
Je ne comprends rien à
cette énigme...
Mais en tout cas, j'ai retiré 2 baguettes...
Je vais les mettre avec les
2 tiges que j'avais.
Je viens d'avoir une idée :
depuis tout à l'heure j'essaye de faire
rentre ça là-dedans, ça ne marche pas du tout.
Et là ! Je viens de me dire...
Ça ressemble un peu à une clef.
Ça a l'air d'être un petit peu une clef...
Donc j'essaye en filmant,
directement avec vous...
Mais ça ne m'a pas l'air d'être ça.
Je crois que non.
Pourtant c'était une bonne piste !
Je viens de trouver un nouveau trou.
Et je sais que cette phrase est
très étrange dire comme ça...
Quand je tourne ça...
En fait, ici, il y a un nouveau trou.
Juste là.
Donc je le tente, mais je le tente bien proche
de la caméra, parce que si c'est ça...
Ah... ça marche pas mal, là...
[Musique - Suspens]
C'est pas mal
Oooh ! Oui !!!
[Rire de surprise]
Ça vient d'éjecter...
tout le cul de la boîte en fait.
Ça actionne un système de ressort
qui maintenait la boîte...
P'tin, c'est un truc de ouf ce qu'il a fait
à l'intérieur le mec!
Pour moi, je n'ai pas fini...
J'ai ouvert la boîte, mais là
je vois bien qu'il y a une boîte dans la boîte !
Ok. En fait j'étais juste très bête...
[Rire]
Il suffisait de décaler un petit peu
l'ensemble pour ressortir cette boîte...
de la boîte !
[Rire]
Xavier !
Je suppose que tu regardes la vidéo,
sache que je connais très
très bien ces boîtes là.
Et ce qui m'a mis la puce à l'oreille,
c'est que tu aies fait tout un entourage ici.
En général, on fait un entourage pour
cacher des jointures.
En fait cette boîte,
elle s'ouvre comme ça.
Et c'est très très malin,
mais du coup je connaissais ça !
C'est très malin parce que ça,
c'est caché par la jointure là et ici.
Et le seul moyen, en fait,
d'ouvrir le tiroir,
c'est d'avoir les deux doigts placés
au bon endroit !
C'est à dire qu'en faisant comme ça,
comme ça...
même comme ça,
ça ne fonctionne pas
C'est juste comme ça
que ça fonctionne.
Regardez, ça fait :
Tout est là, tu y es presque,
soit curieux.
Oh là là, y'en a partout !
"Cours Magica"
J'ai un livre qui s'appelle
Cours Magica
de Robert VENO, que j'avais présenté
dans une de mes bibliothèques...
Donc en 1 on a : X, C, I, V.
En clair, XC, ça c'est 90
Je crois...
Et 4. Et ça c'est 4.
C'est 94.
La carte banquière.
Vous présentez un jeu de cartes
ordinaire, vous cherchez une carte de trèfle
et vous extrayez celle-ci...
de celle-ci, une pièce de monnaie, bien que
vos mains aient été montrées vide auparavant.
Je ne suis pas sûr que
je sois sur la bonne piste,
mais alors, du coup, je ne sais pas
pourquoi il y aurait les Cours Magica..
Bon, c'est énorme !
Je viens de tenter un truc. En fait je tente
plein de choses depuis tout à l'heure,
euh... avec le livre ça ne donnait pas trop
Ah c'est ça !
Et en fait, euh... voilà :
comme je me dis que le mec est Geek
et qu'il a fait ça aussi,
j'ai essayé de taper tout ce que j'avais
sur la boîte, comme une adresse Internet.
Donc, il y avait : 94 en 1,
en 2, il y avait 23,
en 3, c'est 235
et en 4 c'est, euh... 209 !
Si vous voulez essayer, c'est :
94.23.235.209
Il y a toute une animation
qui a commencé à se mettre en cours, là...
Je vais mettre ici pour que vous voyiez.
Et là j'ai bien vu que ça ressemblait
un petit peu à un cerveau...
Donc, je sais que je suis
au bon endroit.
Je sait que c'est ça !
Vous voyez,c'est le cerveau que j'utilise souvent,
sur l'affiche de mon spectacle, etc...
Aaaaahhhh ! Mortel !
C'est un cerveau en 3D !
Regardez !
C'est une constellation en fait,
en réalité.
Trop bien fait.
Je suis bluffé, je suis vraiment bluffé.
Maintenant, j'ai un petit mot
qu'il m'a envoyé sur un autre mail
que j'ai imprimé et que je dois lire
qu'à la fin de la vidéo.
Mais, en résumé, j'ai créé une chasse au trésor
avec un vrai trésor
enterré depuis, maintenant, un peu plus d'un an
quelque part en France.
Je connaissais ce principe,
j'avais fait une vidéo là-dessus
pour une maison d'édition qui a fait
un concept un peu similaire à la Chouette d'Or
en fait, depuis la Chouette d'Or...
Ceux qui savent...
savent ce qu'est la Chouette d'Or !
Et, en une semaine, j'ai donc dessiné la boîte,
inventé un système de clef séquentielle
et construit la boîte.
Non, mais c'est un travail, euh...
Ça dépasse mon entendement.
Je ne suis pas hyper bricoleur en plus...
"Cette histoire est contée dans un livre :
Les neuf énigmes de la Clef du Temps"
"Ce livre, à paraître, permettra d'accéder
aux 9 énigmes et de tenter de les résoudre"
"afin d'accéder à la position du coffre,
qui existe vraiment"
"et qui contient :"
"33 lingotins d'or de 50g
ce qui fait, à l'heure où j'écris ces lignes :"
"61377,36 Euros"
En fait, je vois bien ce qui est en train
de se passer, je ne suis pas fou non plus...
c'est un espèce de placement de produit...
Euh....
Sans que je sache que c'était
un placement de produit au départ.
"Alors, je sais que tu as parlé, il n'y a pas
très longtemps, d'une autre chasse au trésor"
c'est ce que je vous disais
"J'ai bien conscience que tout ça peut être
considéré comme du placement de produit"
C'est ce que je viens de dire.
"Et tout ça est très délicat"
Mais non ! Ce n'est pas délicat.
T'as bien fait !
Et bien écoutez, ça va partir dans un petit
lien dans les commentaires,
si je trouve un lien quelque part
parce qu'il n'y a aucun lien vers ton livre
mon cher Xavier.
Il m'aura fallu plus de 40 minutes,
42 minutes et 26 secondes
pour faire l'ensemble de cette vidéo.
Les deux, trois informations importantes
c'est que j'avais annoncé un live
pour là, pour ce dimanche
Comme c'est Pâques, vous avez été
nombreux à me dire :
"Ah ben non, en fait c'est gênant..."
Alors, je le ferai le 23.
Je sais que c'est les élections le 23
mais ce n'est pas grave,
on va se faire ça le 23 à 17h30
voilà. Le 23 avril, à 17h30,
je compte sur vous
notez-le quelque part.
La 2ème chose, c'est que je suis toujours
en spectacle ; vous avez toutes les dates de tournée
dans la description.
La semaine prochaine, par exemple,
je suis à Mulhouse, et la dernière date
sera à Nantes le 30 juin !
Il n'y a pas d'énigme supplémentaire
dans cette vidéo là
ou alors, c'est vraiment que...
il y a une image...
quelque part...
de π, qui traîne dans cette vidéo...
et que le timing exact !
d'apparition !
de π, vous donnera, encore une fois
un temps d'avance...
pour gagner, ce que vous savez...
dont je parlais dans cette
vidéo là.
Encore une fois, il s'agit simplement
pour vous d'avoir de l'avance
le jour où sortira la vidéo d'énigmes
pour gagner...
ce de... ce dont... je ne dois pas
prononcer le nom.
Si vous êtes encore là à ce stade
de la vidéo, laissez un petit pouce en l'air
pour me le dire. Parce que ça me fait
plaisir et ça veut dire que tout ça vous a plu.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner.
Dans la dernière vidéo, il y avait
les résultats de l'expérience mentale 2.
A très bientôt.
Ciao !
[Musique du générique de fin]